from the cbs broadcast center in new  york  [Music]  through the canyons of buildings in the  center of manhattan  [Music]  to the heart of times square  i'm tony decopal from cbs news  let's take a virtual look inside our new  home  at the heart of every broadcast is the  control room where our crew makes all  that tv magic happen  and this is the very first place all of  our guests cbs mornings come to visit  so now if you want you can be our guest  take a look around  and this is 15 15 our new home for cbs  mornings  and here's the view from the desk where  we'll be giving you all the news you  need and a little bit something extra  just to brighten your day  welcome to cbs mornings i'm gayle king  and i'm tony decopal and i'm they  burleson let's go to today's eyeopener  it's your world in 90 seconds and if you  could be so kind you can watch us live  every morning at 7 only on cbs  and stream us live on paramount plus  [Music]